¿Quién no ama la eficiencia? Yo sí.
La eficiencia significa más por menos.
Más kilómetros por litro, más luz por vatio, más palabras por minuto.
Más por menos es lo mejor que hay después de algo por nada.
Algoritmos, big data, la nube, nos están dando más por menos.
¿Nos dirigimos hacia una utopía libre de fricción
o hacia una pesadilla de vigilancia?
No lo sé.
Me interesa el presente,
y me gustaría mostrarles cómo el pasado puede ayudarnos a entender el presente.
No hay nada que resuma mejor lo prometedor
y a la vez lo peligroso de la eficiencia
como la humilde papa.
La papa se originó en los Andes y se extendió a Europa
desde los antiguos incas.
La papa es una obra maestra de la nutrición equilibrada.
Y tuvo amigos muy poderosos.
El rey Federico el Grande de Prusia fue el primer entusiasta.
Él creía que la papa podría ayudar a aumentar
la población de prusianos saludables,
y mientras más prusianos saludables, más soldados prusianos saludables.
Y algunos de esos soldados prusianos saludables
capturaron a un farmacéutico militar francés llamado Parmentier.
Parmentier, al principio, estaba horrorizado por la dieta a base de papas
con la que alimentaban a los prisioneros de guerra de mañana, tarde y noche,
pero terminó disfrutándola.
Pensó que lo estaban haciendo una persona más sana.
Y así, cuando fue liberado, se encargó de extender la papa a Francia.
Y tenía algunos amigos poderosos.
Benjamin Franklin le aconsejó que celebrara un banquete
en el que cada plato tuviera papas,
y Franklin fue un invitado de honor.
Incluso el rey y la reina de Francia fueron persuadidos para lucir papas.
Flores de papa, discúlpenme.
El rey llevaba una flor de patata en la solapa,
y la reina llevaba una flor de patata en el cabello.
Esa fue una gran idea de relaciones públicas.
Pero había una trampa.
La papa era demasiado eficiente para el bien de Europa.
En Irlanda, parecía un milagro.
Las papas florecieron, la población creció.
Pero había un riesgo oculto.
Las papas de Irlanda eran genéticamente idénticas.
Eran una raza muy eficiente llamada "Lumper".
El problema con el Lumper era que una plaga venida de América del Sur,
que afectaba a una sola papa, terminaría afectándolas a todas.
La explotación y la insensibilidad de Gran Bretaña
tuvieron su responsabilidad, pero fue debido a este monocultivo
que murieron un millón de personas y otros dos millones debieron emigrar.
Una planta que supuestamente terminaría con la hambruna
creó una de las más trágicas.
Los problemas de eficiencia hoy son menos drásticos, pero más crónicos.
También pueden prolongar los males que estaban destinados a resolver.
Veamos por ejemplo los registros médicos electrónicos.
Parecían ser la respuesta al problema de la escritura a mano de los médicos
y tenía el beneficio de brindar datos mucho mejores para los tratamientos.
En la práctica, en cambio,
ha significado mucho más papeleo electrónico,
y los médicos ahora se quejan de que tienen menos tiempo
en lugar de más para ver a los pacientes individualmente.
La obsesión por la eficiencia puede hacernos menos eficientes.
La eficiencia también responde con falsos positivos.
Los hospitales tienen cientos de dispositivos que registran alarmas.
Con demasiada frecuencia son falsas alarmas.
Lleva tiempo descartarlas,
y ese tiempo resulta en fatiga, estrés y, una vez más,
el descuido de los problemas de pacientes reales.
También hay falsos positivos en el reconocimiento de patrones.
Un autobús escolar visto desde el ángulo equivocado
puede parecerse a un saco de boxeo,
por lo tanto, se requiere de tiempo valioso
para eliminar la identificación errónea.
Los falsos negativos también son un problema.
Los algoritmos pueden aprender mucho, rápido,
pero solo pueden contarnos sobre el pasado.
Muchos clásicos futuros reciben malas críticas, como Moby Dick,
o son rechazados por varios editores, como la serie de Harry Potter.
Puede ser un desperdicio tratar de evitar todo desperdicio.
La eficiencia también es una trampa cuando la oposición la copia.
Veamos por ejemplo la pieza de artillería francesa de 75 milímetros
de finales del siglo XIX.
Fue una obra maestra de diseño letal.
Esta pieza podría disparar un proyectil cada cuatro segundos.
Pero eso no era tan inusual.
Lo realmente brillante fue que, debido al mecanismo de retroceso,
podía regresar exactamente a la misma posición sin tener que ser reorientado.
Entonces, la tasa efectiva de disparo aumentó drásticamente.
Ahora, esta parecía ser una forma para que Francia derrotara a Alemania
la próxima vez que pelearan.
Pero, como era previsible, los alemanes estaban trabajando en algo muy similar.
Entonces, cuando estalló la Primera Guerra Mundial,
el resultado fue la guerra de trincheras que duró más de lo esperado.
Una tecnología diseñada para acortar la guerra, la prolongó.
El mayor costo de todos pueden ser las oportunidades perdidas.
La economía de plataforma que conecta a compradores y vendedores
puede ser una gran inversión, y lo hemos visto en las últimas semanas.
Compañías que todavía están perdiendo cientos de millones de dólares
pueden estar creando multimillonarios con ofertas públicas iniciales.
Pero los inventos realmente difíciles son los físicos y químicos.
Significan mayores riesgos.
Pueden estar perdiéndose porque el hardware es difícil.
Es mucho más difícil escalar una invención física o química
que una invención basada en software.
Piensen en las baterías.
Las baterías de iones de litio que hay
en dispositivos portátiles y automóviles eléctricos
se basan en un principio de hace 30 años.
¿Cuántas baterías de teléfonos inteligentes de hoy
durarían un día completo con una sola carga?
Sí, el hardware es difícil.
Llevó más de 20 años
que las patentes del "principio de fotocopiado en seco"
de Chester Carlson de 1938,
dieran como resultado la copiadora Xerox 914
lanzada en 1959.
La pequeña y valiente compañía Haloid, de Rochester, Nueva York,
tuvo que pasar por lo que la mayoría de las corporaciones nunca habrían tolerado.
Hubo una falla tras otra, y uno de los problemas especiales fue el fuego.
De hecho, cuando finalmente se lanzó la 914,
todavía tenía un dispositivo
llamado "eliminador de quemaduras",
pero en realidad era un pequeño extintor incorporado.
Mi respuesta a todas estas preguntas es la ineficiencia inspirada.
Los datos y la medición son esenciales, pero no son suficientes.
Dejemos espacio para la intuición humana y las habilidades humanas.
Hay siete facetas de ineficiencia inspirada.
Primero, por ejemplo, veamos la ruta panorámica, decir "sí" a la serendipia.
Los giros incorrectos pueden ser productivos.
Una vez, cuando estaba explorando la orilla este del Mississippi,
tomé el camino equivocado.
Me estaba acercando a un puente de peaje que cruza el Gran Río,
y el recaudador dijo que no podía regresar.
Entonces, pagué mis 50 centavos, eso era todo en ese momento,
y estaba en Muscatine, Iowa.
Apenas había oído hablar de Muscatine, pero resultó ser un lugar fascinante.
Muscatine tenía uno de los bancos de mejillones más ricos del mundo.
Hace un siglo, un tercio de los botones del mundo se producían en Muscatine,
1500 millones al año.
Las últimas plantas están cerradas, pero todavía hay un museo de la industria
de los botones de perlas que es uno de los más inusuales del mundo.
Pero los botones fueron solo el comienzo.
Esta es la casa en Muscatine donde el futuro presidente de China
se quedó en 1986 como miembro de una delegación agrícola.
Ahora es la casa de la amistad de las relaciones entre China y EE.UU.,
y es un sitio de peregrinación para turistas chinos.
¿Cómo podría yo haber previsto eso?
Segundo, levantarse del sofá.
A veces puede ser más eficiente hacer las cosas de la manera difícil.
Consideremos la Internet de las cosas.
Es maravilloso poder controlar las luces, configurar el termostato,
e incluso aspirar la habitación sin dejar nuestros asientos,
pero la investigación médica ha demostrado que estar inquieto,
levantarse y caminar, es una de las mejores cosas
que se puede hacer por el corazón.
Es bueno para el corazón y la cintura.
Tercero, monetizar tus errores.
Se pueden crear grandes formas mediante el desarrollo imaginativo de accidentes.
Tad Leski, un arquitecto de la Ópera Metropolitana del Lincoln Center,
estaba trabajando en un boceto y un poco de tinta blanca cayó sobre el dibujo.
Es posible que otras personas lo hayan tirado a la basura,
pero Leski se inspiró para producir un candelabro en forma de estrella
que probablemente fue el más notable de su tipo del siglo XX.
Cuarto, a veces intentar por las malas.
Puede ser más eficiente ser menos fluido.
Los psicólogos llaman a esto una dificultad deseable.
Tomar notas detalladas con un teclado parece ser la mejor manera de comprender
lo que dice el profesor para poder revisarlo al pie de la letra.
Sin embargo, los estudios han demostrado que cuando tenemos que abreviar,
cuando tenemos que resumir lo que dice un hablante, cuando tomamos notas
con un bolígrafo o un lápiz sobre papel, estamos procesando esa información.
Lo hacemos nuestro y estamos aprendiendo mucho más activamente
que cuando simplemente transcribimos lo que se dice.
Quinto, obtener seguridad a través de la diversidad.
El monocultivo puede ser mortal, ¿recuerdan la papa?
Fue eficiente hasta que no lo fue.
La diversidad también se aplica a las organizaciones.
El software puede decir qué fue lo que hizo
que personas en una organización tuvieran éxito en el pasado,
y es útil, a veces, en la selección de empleados,
pero recuerden que el entorno cambia constantemente y que el software,
el software de selección, no tiene forma de saberlo, y no tenemos forma de saber
quién será útil en el futuro.
Por lo tanto, debemos complementar lo que el algoritmo nos diga con intuición
y buscando personas con diversos antecedentes y perspectivas.
Sexto, lograr la seguridad
a través de la redundancia y las habilidades humanas.
¿Por qué se estrellaron dos aviones 737 Max?
Todavía no conocemos la historia completa,
pero sabemos cómo prevenir futuras tragedias.
Necesitamos múltiples sistemas independientes.
Si uno falla, los otros pueden anularlo.
También necesitamos operadores calificados que vengan al rescate,
y eso significa capacitación constante.
Siete, ser racionalmente extravagantes.
Thomas Edison fue un pionero de la industria del cine,
así como de la tecnología de cámaras.
Nadie ha hecho más por la eficiencia que Thomas Edison,
pero su corte transversal se dañó.
Su gerente contrató a un llamado "ingeniero de eficiencia",
que le aconsejó que ahorrara dinero usando más del rollo de película
que había filmado, teniendo menos regrabaciones.
Bueno, Edison era un genio, pero no entendía las nuevas reglas
de los largometrajes y el hecho de que
el fracaso se estaba convirtiendo en el precio del éxito.
Por otro lado, algunos grandes directores, como Erich von Stroheim,
fueron todo lo contrario.
Eran excelentes dramaturgos, y Stroheim también fue un actor memorable,
pero no podían trabajar dentro de sus presupuestos,
entonces eso no era sostenible.
Fue Irving Thalberg, un exsecretario con una genialidad intuitiva,
quien logró una extravagancia racional.
Primero en Universal, luego en MGM,
convirtiéndose en el ideal del productor de Hollywood.
En resumen, para ser verdaderamente eficientes,
necesitamos una ineficiencia óptima.
El camino más corto puede ser una curva en lugar de una línea recta.
Charles Darwin lo entendió.
Cuando se encontró con un problema difícil,
hizo un recorrido por un sendero,
el camino de arena que había construido detrás de su casa.
Un camino productivo puede ser físico, como el de Darwin, o virtual,
o un desvío imprevisto de un camino que habíamos trazado.
Demasiada eficiencia puede debilitarlo,
pero un poco de ineficiencia inspirada puede fortalecerlo.
A veces, la mejor manera de avanzar es seguir un círculo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)